we've got two great films in the
festival what does that feel like it
feels great you know it's you know i
love the festival obviously and it's
great to be here and to show these films
that i'm really really proud of course
there's also lots of Oscar buzz around
12 years a slave how does that feel for
you and how do you think she things
might change if come the night in march
next year they hand over that little
statue well it's been this really
exciting time and with i mean i'm just
thrilled to have made the film really
and and and to make 12 years a slave
into and you know had the privilege of
shooting half of a Yellow Sun and in
Nigeria and so I mean that's it'll in a
way that's the you know it's a great
reward in itself is to have to be able
to open it and show these films to
people and so I'm excited for that
really I mean a little bit about how the
experience of filming it to the film's
12 years and also of course a half of
the Yellow Sun compared well I mean they
were very different phones but I shot
them actually one after the other so it
was very interesting to go from Nigeria
and a film about some of the conflict
there and and go straight and to you
know fly over to Louisiana to discuss
you know a film that you know to be in a
film that also develops it discusses
conflicts that involved Nigeria involved
in the slave trade involved that exact
area you know the Nigeria and the Bight
of Benin around there which is where we
were shooting in caliber which is why i
visited you know the the slave museums
there before i left and so the two
projects are they very different had
certain connections help you in a way
kind of moved from one to the other yeah
it was a good way to transition into
another into another thing and it was it
was a very interesting way to start that
process finally we know coming up next
for you said the Zachariah can you tell
us a little bit about your role in that
and what you're looking forward to in
that film well so generally I mean I I
mean it's a it's a it's an adaptation
we're still figuring it out all the
stuff of it but there's an adaptation of
a book of the same name and so you know
we're hopefully going to start shooting
that pretty soon and
and I'm just kind of you know reading
and looking at stuff and enjoying this
time of introducing these films will be
very finely of course you're soaring in
that with on Chris Pine from Star Trek
who works with JJ Abrams if JJ Abrams
came knocking for one of the Star Wars
movies what would be your reaction well
we'll see if it happens you know I'm not
gonna tell you thanks go
you